When the news of the bombing came out,
it was a massive story in Germany.
We are following some
breaking news coming to us
out of Dortmund in Germany.
It was covered by all
of the media outlets.
Three roadside explosions triggered
at the same time last night,
as a coach left its hotel
in the south of Dortmund.
Public figures commented on it.
We should not let them affect
our life whoever it was.
The media echo went far beyond Dortmund.
I think it was front page news
in every single big paper around Europe.
Everyone thought of
like a terrorist attack
and people were scared that
throughout the city in Dortmund,
there was more attacks to be happening.
Unbeknownst to investigators
just after the bomb went off
and the players of the
team were shell shocked,
the person who had masterminded the attack
was actually sitting in the hotel,
eating steak and sweet potatoes.
My name is Thomas Rogers.
I'm the journalist who wrote the article
The Get Rich Quick Scheme
That Nearly Killed a German Soccer Team.
Dortmund is a mid-sized city
in the western part of Germany
in the state called
North Rhine-Westphalia.
And it's a former industrial city
that's kind of fallen on hard
times in the last few decades.
It was severely bombed in the war.
So the center of the city is quite stark.
Some of the few high points
includes its soccer team.
My name is Eyk Henning,
I'm a reporter with Bloomberg news
and I'm a great fan of Borussia Dortmund.
Dortmund fans are super loyal.
On all match days the entire
city is in black and yellow,
it's like a religion.
I think more than most German cities,
soccer does play a very large role
in the identity of Dortmund.
In October of 2000,
the BVB became the first
team in the Bundesliga
to actually go public.
Salaries for soccer
players in the Bundesliga
have gone up very dramatically.
With such high prices they
thought that by going public,
they would be able to compete better
with big teams like Bayern Munich.
Unfortunately, that didn't go too well.
Dortmund bought too many
expensive players, high wages,
and the club almost went bust in 2005.
But the price of their shares,
it has sometimes gone up,
but mostly gone down since
they made that decision.
So on April 11th, 2017
the team was staying in a hotel
on the outskirts of Dortmund.
Match days are always special in Dortmund
everyone is looking forward to it.
The team always meets in the
same hotel ahead of matches.
They stayed in this hotel
in order to have a kind of
a neutral space before games
so that they could concentrate
be sort of isolated
from distractions, things like that.
Everyone was pretty
optimistic they had a chance
to go really far, maybe into the finals.
I was in the office and
getting ready for match day,
was gonna meet with a friend
a fellow Dortmund supporter in a pub.
As always the fans are
very excited about matches.
On that day, they were heading
to play in the quarter-final
against AS Monaco at Signal Iduna stadium,
which is in the center of Dortmund.
Shortly before 7:00 PM,
the players of the team bordered
their official team bus.
When the bus took off the
parking lot of the hotel
and turned on the street
there were three detonations,
three bombs that exploded
and hit the bus of Dortmund.
Three explosions occurred,
close to the Borussia Dortmund team bus.
The B team bus had just left the hotel.
The explosions destroyed two windows
in the rear part of the bus.
People screamed,
people jumped to the ground.
The fellow Dortmund fan
I was supposed to watch the match with,
he called me and said "Turn on the TV,
there was an attack on the Dortmund bus".
And I thought that was impossible.
Some of the players screamed at the driver
to keep driving as fast as possible
because they were worried that
people might storm the bus.
German investigators said
the explosive devices
used in the attack on
the Borussia Dortmund bus
contained metal pins.
One had pierced a seat head rest.
Unbeknownst to the team members
the actual mastermind behind the attack
was as they were disembarking the bus,
was actually eating
steak and sweet potatoes
at the hotel they had just left.
Authorities are attempting to verify
a letter left at the scene,
claiming jihadists were behind the attack.
Because there had been a series of attacks
by Islamic terrorists
in Germany and Europe,
there was a widespread
suspicion in the media
that this was another
Islamic terror attack.
Three letters were found
at the site of the bombing
that took credit for the attack
on behalf of Islamic State.
There were however reasons
to doubt this particular narrative.
It would actually be a surprise
if ISIS were actually
part of this attack.
Possibly, could be, employed by other groups
like the far-right wing to
try and shift the blame.
The letters had some strange qualities.
They were written in a strange German
that used big sophisticated words,
but had basic grammar mistakes
as if someone was native German speaker,
but pretending to be a foreign person.
Federal investigators
have detained one man,
suspected of links to Islamist terrorism.
One of two suspects whose apartments
were raided this morning.
Shortly after the bombing,
a man in Austria named
Rudolf, who was a big BVB fan,
he noticed that something
strange was going on
on the stock market
related to the team shares.
He emailed the lawyers of BVB
who then forwarded that
email on to investigators.
The email stated that someone
had bought 60,000 BVB put options.
A wager that the value
of the shares of the team
would fall below a certain
amount, at a certain date.
Why would someone buy
that ahead of a match
and then three bombs go off?
Something, something isn't right here.
For the person to make money off of that
it required the stock
to go down quite a bit
in a fairly short period of time.
And it wouldn't just be
the team losing a match
it would require something
much bigger than that.
There was another big red
flag about this purchase,
which is the fact that it
had actually been made
number one on the day of the bombing,
but also from an IP address
that had been traced
to the actual hotel where
the bombing had taken place.
When three explosions targeted the bus,
carrying the Borussia Dortmund
footballers on April 11th
written notes left at the
scene claimed the attack
was the work of ISIL.
The truth as is now
alleged, is remarkable.
On April 21st, the police arrested a man
in a southern German city called Tübingen.
He was on his way to work
and his name was Sergej Wenergold.
He seemed like an unlikely suspect
because he had no known connections
to the Islamic terror world.
He didn't seem like a far-right extremist,
he didn't seem like a left-wing extremist either.
He seemed to be a completely
unremarkable young man.
A 28-year-old German-Russian
man named only as Sergej. W,
stayed in the same hotel as the players
on the night before the bombing.
He specifically requested an upper room,
overlooking the bushes
where the explosive devices were hidden.
The media dissected why he would do that.
What was his past?
He had been inspired by the
2015 terror attack in Paris.
And he noticed that in the
aftermath of the attack,
the stocks of French companies went down
and he believed that if
an attack took place,
that was directed at a specific company
that the decrease in stock
price for that company
would be even more dramatic.
It never occurred to anyone
that someone would do that out of greed.
We now know that the suspect
bought three different derivatives
on the Borussia Dortmund shares.
With all these derivatives
he bet on falling shares.
The suspect bought the majority
of these financial products
on the 11th of April.
The day of the attack.
If the plot had been completely successful
and the stock had reached a value of zero,
Wenergold would have made up to €570,000
or the equivalent of about $608,000.
Ultimately the plan completely backfired.
The attacker Sergej Wenergold
didn't make any money.
In fact, he lost money.
In court he would be extremely quiet.
He usually kept his
hands clasped together.
One of the lawyers actually commented that
he had never seen a
defendant act so calmly.
Wenergold had served some
time in the German military.
From that information
and from online research,
he was able to figure out how to assemble
remote detonated bombs that
would do what he hoped to do.
There were a few days of
extremely emotional testimony,
including the soccer players
who described doubting
whether or not they could
ever play another game again.
It brought everything back up
and it didn't quite help
them to kind of process
what was going on.
Throughout it all he
sat there completely silent.
The big mystery that was
swirling around the trial
was the question of why?
He may have simply done it because
he wanted to impress a woman.
Rebecca is a young woman who
has a very troubled home life.
She ultimately sees her
relationship with Wenergold
as an opportunity to
leave that troubled home.
Wenergold is a Russian
immigrant to Germany,
he speaks with an accent,
he has anxiety in large groups of Germans.
She begins to resent the
fact that he has these fears
and feels a little bit trapped.
Rebecca attempts to dump
him on multiple occasions
and he threatens to commit
suicide if she leaves him.
Wenergold apparently told Rebecca
that she would soon be seeing a surprise.
After being dumped via text message,
he apparently began planning
for this attack in earnest.
Wenergold was charged with 28
counts of attempted murder,
which carried a maximum
sentence in Germany
of life in prison.
He claimed that he had
nothing to do with the attack,
but as time went on,
he admitted that he had
actually been the person
who had built the explosives
and had set them off.
But he claimed that he didn't
want to actually kill anybody.
Ultimately Wenergold didn't receive
the harshest possible sentence.
He was given 14 years in prison,
but it's still a considerable
amount in jail, in Germany.